scientists are frantically copying
climate data fearing that it might be
deleted or made to disappear under
President Donald Trump they're so afraid
are these scientists that decades of
data that they've been working on could
be eliminated under a Donald Trump
administration that they've established
independent servers or they can copy off
tons of government data to try to
protect it from potential political
interference this includes an effort of
guerrilla archiving in Toronto this
includes meetings at the University of
Pennsylvania try to figure out how to
download as much federal data as
possible this includes scientists and
database experts that are collaborating
to figure out how to create a sort of
safe harbor for scientific information
and why is this happening well it's
happening because president-elect Donald
Trump is nominated this ever-growing
list of camp cabinet members who have
questioned the scientific consensus on
global warming the transition team at
the Department of Energy has demanded
the names of agency officials who were
involved in international climate talks
to work on what we know to be the
scientific basis for Obama
administration regulations of carbon
emissions they want names Pat and I
understand the fear yeah I don't think
they're being paranoid at all if you
look at Trump's position on climate
change in his more authoritarian
tendencies like cracking down on a free
flow of information one Trump advisor
suggested that NASA should not be
allowed to conduct climate research
anymore because it's become too
political and of course Trump himself is
called cute human-caused climate change
a hoax perpetrated by the Chinese for
the benefit of the Chinese economy and
Pat said he doesn't think it's paranoia
is it paranoia or preparedness the
scientists involved are saying no no no
this is preparedness this is one of the
major issues of our time climate change
in what we're doing to our planet and
according to a Sierra Club report when
Trump assumes the presidency on january
twentieth he will be the only head of
state in the world to deny what we know
as mainstream consensus climate science
and that includes Kim jong-un of North
Korea North Korea is more science
based then Trump on the issue of climate
change and look at the wide coalition of
world leaders who got together to uh
sign the Paris climate Accord and now
Trump has even threatened to pull out of
that there's precedent for the fear that
scientists have though because Stephen
Harper did something similar in Canada
where he attempted to silence climate
scientists and in a few cases some data
sets were taken offline all together and
forget for a second about the issue of
climate change specifically if we ever
have a president deleting data from
research that doesn't agree with the
position of their administration we've
got far bigger problems on our hands and
you know what if they appoint cabinet
members ideologically opposed to the
departments that they had that would be
really bad also oh wait a second Rick
Perry to the Department of Energy who
doesn't think that we should have a
Department of Energy Scott Pruett to the
Environmental Protection Agency a guy
whose career has been based on the
opposite of protecting the environment
at the big problem we are really really
in for it I've talked about how people
of all ages but particularly Millennials
are owning cars less and participating
more in the sharing economy and one of
the more popular options is zip car
which gets you a car when you want it
when you need it they offer all sorts of
cars SUVs hybrids whatever you need it
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online from your smartphone over
the phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com slash david support our
show reduce your carbon emissions and
you're spending on cars sign up at
joined zipcar dot-com slash david